vamos a pensar ahora en regiones tipo 2
y verás que en realidad son definiciones
muy similares y que realmente sólo es
una cuestión de orientación entonces
vamos a ir plasmando estas ideas tenemos
una región de tipo 2 vamos a definir
esto que es una región de tipo 2 y vamos
a escribirlo de la siguiente forma como
en términos con juntistas vamos a
definir una región de tipo 2 es un
conjunto de todas las ternas xz que
viven en el espacio tales que ahora en
el tipo 1 lo que teníamos era un dominio
en las coordenadas x y aquí lo que vamos
a tener es en realidad un dominio pero
en otras coordenadas vamos a tener un
dominio en las coordenadas ye z es decir
que los puntos ya z pertenecen a cierto
dominio vamos a llamarle a un dominio
ok entonces pertenecen a cierto dominio
2 y ahora lo que vamos a pedir es que
nuestra coordenada x esté acotada por
arriba y por abajo por dos funciones
entonces que tengamos una función que
uno que dependa de ye y dz que sea menor
o igual que nuestra coordenada x y que
sea
menor o igual x que una segunda función
g 2 de g
muy bien entonces este tipo de regiones
son las tipo 2 que como pueden ver son
muy similares y lo que podemos hacer es
es es revisar con esta otra definición
de región tipo 1 si se dan cuenta
simplemente es una cuestión de
perspectiva una cuestión de orientación
porque ahora vamos a fijarnos en un
dominio que esté sobre el plano y st
estamos pensando digamos en el muro que
se ve de este de este lado entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es vamos a comparar
con estas tres superficies que ya
teníamos cuáles de estas tres son
también regiones de tipo de tipo 2 y
para eso vamos a poner algunos
algunos ejes aquí tenemos nuestro eje y
empecemos por ejemplo con la esfera
vamos a empezar con la esfera
y empecemos
y necesitamos definir un dominio en
nuestro en nuestro muro receta aquí
tenemos a y aquí tenemos a z vamos a
definir un dominio que para fines de la
esfera lo que podemos hacer es utilizar
un círculo unitario como ya es digamos
clásico utilizando este círculo espero
se dé muy bien la idea de que está
colocado justo sobre el plano de zeta
muy bien entonces lo que tenemos que
hacer es ahora x acotarlo por dos
funciones que en este caso es muy
sencillo porque podemos poner que una de
esas funciones
una de esas funciones es digamos el
casco de atrás de nuestra de nuestra
esfera ok digamos estamos pensando en
esta función
más o menos y qué bueno al menos un
poquito coloreado espero ceder muy bien
clara la idea de que estamos pensando en
que es la parte posterior la parte que
está detrás de la esfera es esa parte
ahora bien nuestra función ésta va a ser
que 2 y nuestro dominio de 2 es ésta
esté este esta circunferencia pero ahora
vamos a definir un dominio y perdón a
una función g 2 que en este caso pues
podría ser la la parte de enfrente de
nuestra esfera que digamos esto es como
una especie de ecuador
y se puede más o menos ver así y
entonces lo que vamos a tener es esta
parte frontal de nuestra esfera ok y
entonces ya tenemos nuestras dos
funciones definidas aquí está nuestra
función g 2 nuestra función g 1 y
podemos ver entonces que la esfera no
sólo es una región de tipo 1 sino
también es de tipo 2 y en el próximo
vídeo vídeo veremos que también será de
tipo 3 vamos ahora a ver qué ocurre con
él con el cilindro el cilindro si se
acuerdan era más o menos una
estaba más o menos de estar en esta
parte de arriba que podemos definir
nuestro dominio en el plano de z como un
rectángulo
y este rectángulo en el dominio z
correcto muy bien y ahora lo que vamos a
necesitar es una función que por abajo y
acote a nuestra coordenada x que en este
caso puede ser la media circunferencia
o más bien digamos el medio cilindro que
más o menos se ve por aquí atrás ok
estamos pensando en esta función
y que nos da una superficie trasera
digamos esta sería nuestra g1
también tendremos bueno esto está esta
región azul esta es nuestra región de
dos que es la región en donde está
definido en los puntos 10 eta y ahora
necesitamos una que es una función que
esté por delante
digamos que sea esta otra parte de la
circunferencia
o menos así vamos a dibujar un poco
menos mejor esta caída
y así queda correcto entonces esta parte
de adelante es nuestra función c1 c1 y
es la que define también al cilindro
como una una superficie de tipo 2
vámonos con la última con el último
ejemplo
vamos a tomar este último ejemplo en
donde teníamos nuestra especie de reloj
de arena entonces aquí en la superficie
vamos a recordar un poquito la figura
este es el reloj de arena entonces
podemos definir en el plano z justo esta
figura que más o menos hace
este reloj
ok que de que debe quedar claro que en
realidad esta figura está únicamente en
el plano que se está ahora qué es lo que
vamos a hacer
análogamente definimos que esta región
de atrás esta región de atrás del reloj
de arena sea nuestra función g1
esta esta de aquí
y de frente también necesitamos
definirla entonces tenemos una función
aquí
y definida para todos estos valores de
gm déjenme ver si puedo dibujarlo de
forma que al menos se entienda que es lo
que estamos haciendo
más o menos es esta superficie muy bien
entonces también ya pudimos ver que
nuestra nuestra superficie del reloj de
arena se puede ver como una región de
tipo de tipo 2 ahora sí
si nosotros rotamos si nosotros rotamos
vamos a hacer una de un reloj de arena
un poco rotado si por ejemplo hacemos el
reloj de arena de la siguiente forma que
la tapa superior este de este lado y
entonces el reloj de arena hace algo así
- ok si tenemos aquí nuestro reloj de
arena entonces de la forma parecida como
vimos en el vídeo anterior éste no puede
ser una región de tipo 2 no es región de
tipo 2 porque por ejemplo nuestra
función
nuestra función no podemos definir dos
funciones que atacó también a la equis y
nos damos cuenta de aquí acá hay como
como algunas partes en donde tienen que
ser funciones distintas entonces ese es
exactamente el mismo argumento no
podemos tener dos funciones que acoten a
equis pero ésta está si es de tipo 1
podemos definir una región en en el
plano xy y después acotar a z por dos
funciones pero ésta no puede ser de tipo